Now, project settings overall is something
I want to first talk about because the project settings
contains a huge different variety of settings
for your project.
From in here, we can do everything
such as change the renderer that's
used for Unreal Engine 5 to be forward renderer.
If we're making a VR project, we
could also enable or disable ray tracing
for either hardware or software or even implement a custom
ray tracing or global illumination thing that we'd
like to use for our project.
I highly encourage that everybody go through this
and have a look at the various settings that
are inside of here because, again, there's
just so much to this.
And some of these things will have a direct result
on how your project looks.
For example, as I was talking about forward rendering for a VR
project, this is going to change the renderer,
thus changing the way that things will look.
So it's better to enable this now
than towards the end of your project
when you realize you have to maybe remake
a bunch of materials or adjust source
assets to accommodate for these changes in the renderer.
One of the other things I'd like to mention about this
is that when you are adjusting things inside of here,
oftentimes you do need to restart the editor in order
to see that change.
So make sure that once you have adjusted something,
you restart the editor so that those changes can
take place.
Oftentimes, the reason you don't see something working
is because this step was forgotten about
or maybe overlooked because you were enabling or disabling
other options, and you just simply forgot about that.
So remember, restarting the editor
is the best way to see these effects happen on your project.
And remember, go through, have a look, and explore
because there's a lot of things inside of here
that can really help your project out
in terms of performance and optimization.